how much of a perfectionist was michael
jackson
how much of a perfectionist am i was
michael jackson michael was the ultimate
perfectionist in fact
i learned so much from him because of
that
michael knew
the dance steps obviously his singing
but he knew the background singers what
they should be doing
uh when the lights should be coming on
the costumes like he knew everybody
else's jobs and there's there's video
you can watch it when michael's
performing live and sometimes like the
music is not quite right he'll be
performing but he'll just point
point to the music director
it's like okay like you better fix it
because it's not sounding right
something is off either it's too slow
it's too fast the music is on the wrong
pitch or whatever the situation is he's
on it and so
um he was very much a perfectionist and
i learned a lot from him because he
doesn't quit until it's perfect he
doesn't quit rehearsals until it's right
he keeps going and going and going and
that's something that i've picked up
from him a lot of is is
you know
we would do like so like back when we
were choreographing it together as a
team and we would choreograph something
and we thought it was the most amazingly
hot thing okay we're going gonna show
mike like showcase this to michael
and we do it and it's like you know is
that the best that it can be
and like
you know you begin to doubt yourself
like could it be better like maybe yeah
so we go back to the lab and start
working on some more dance steps so that
was a question that i have in my mind
from time to time is this the best that
it can be
whether it's the writing of a script
how the scene is done when i'm when i'm
directing it or staging it is this the
best that it can be and sometimes the
answer is it's the best that it needs to
be right now
because we don't have a lot of time to
make it perfect perfect perfect like not
everyone has given david fitcher time
and david fincher money to do 100 takes
99 takes you know he did 99 takes for
the opening of of um
the social network which is insane
99 takes of that opening scene where
they're in the bar
back and forth and he's talking about
you know the you know the genius level
of people who live in china and it's
like
okay i get the point of like getting it
right
but then there's another level of that
and you the the jobs that i've worked on
as a director like i'm shooting i'm
shooting feature films in 12 days like i
don't have the ability to do more than
maybe three or four takes tops
um
and so
yeah i can't
there's a there's a give and take you
know to being a perfectionist
in this
world of of directing
when you have a limited budget and a
limited amount of time if you have a
limited time and budget then yeah you
can do whatever you want to do but i
don't have that luxury on the projects
that i've worked on
from the other names that you've worked
with because you've worked with similar
great talent how much do you see
perfectionism in them yeah and is this a
trait that
you either develop once you're there or
that's what got them there yeah i would
say the trait of perfectionism um is
what gets them there the the ability to
and the attempt to work hard is what
gets them there but again they're all
looking at michael and that's why a lot
of these people the ushers that i worked
with the beyonces that i've worked with
um
um and other people
the britney spears that i work with they
surround themselves with people that
have worked with michael because they
want some of that magic and they know
that they're going to be pushed so
beyonce is known for having that trait
now but she got that because she's
worked with people that has worked with
michael jackson
she now she did have it within her and
also her father matthew
like he pushed he pushed those girls
like when they were you know destiny's
child when it was like you know the
original four girls like he would make
them run around the track singing like
full vocals like he put that in them but
for beyonce to hire people that have
been around the best
you know she knows what she's doing and
she's able to
glean from that and now apply within
herself so that's why she's one of the
most amazing you know and talented
performers out there because of that
what do you see as the downside to being
a perfectionist
uh the downside of being perfectionist
is um well i mean your interpersonal
relationships
um
you know i think also you
you could
push people
too hard
uh because i think there's a limit you
know there's there's a point where you
have this this level of diminishing
returns you know doing it again is not
going to make it that much better
so i think
when people are at that point when
they're only
doing it over and over and over again
they don't necessarily look at the fact
that okay this is the best it's going to
be
either for this this this performance or
today's rehearsal sometimes they don't
know when to quit
so it's like this blessing on this curse
you know it's it's a blessing in the
fact that they're getting the steps as
best as they can be but at a certain
point it's like okay it's not going to
get much better than this and sometimes
people don't know when to stop
what did michael jackson teach you about
being an artist
wow that's a great question what did
michael jackson teach me about being an
artist
i think kind of work on the line of of
perfectionists is
is to not settle
and to ask is it good enough
and i think that's something that i like
to deal with all everything that i work
on but i have i have the other piece to
it understanding that at a certain point
you know you can keep rewriting that
script over and over again
but at a certain point you got to get
the script out there for people to see
it
otherwise it will never get made
so
um
i i constantly ask myself is it good
enough
but i understand that a certain point it
is good enough
it may not be perfect but it's good
enough
and
you know i need to get this thing made
or i need to get this thing shot
so
you know for for me
the big thing that i learned from him is
it's just a question isn't good enough
do the same rules apply to dancing did
he teach you the same about dancing it's
the same
yeah in regards to dancing it's the same
rule you know can it be better
is is a constant question that i ask
myself which is why when i learned the
dance steps i had to do them with full
energy as we again as a dancer we call
that dancing full out i couldn't dance
things with half energy because of the
fact that i will never know if it's good
enough
so how do i know unless i'm actually
giving it my all
um
and then when you kind of start from
this level here you know even just this
much of an increase
is is is
is
head over heels better than a lot of
other dancers and so that's why i worked
so much was because of the fact that
having that early experience of working
with him and seeing how he worked i was
able to push myself
to get to heights other dancers couldn't
get to
they can maybe spin more than me
they can probably jump higher than me
but you can't outperform me and that's
one thing that i was never going to be
you know outperformed by another dancer
did you tell yourself that early on yeah
i told myself that early on is because
some people are actually born flexible
you know some people are born with the
ability to put their leg next to their
head you know so when they kick it it
goes amazingly i wasn't born with that
like i was very
very tight when i first started dancing
and even though i was able to get my leg
here i couldn't get it back here and so
you know what do you do in that case you
just give up like oh i can't dance like
this person i can't get my leg that high
i can't spend this many times it's like
no what other assets can i bring to the
table that this person possibly can
bring well i'm gonna be a hell of a
performer you know so when you when i
dance when we're dancing next to each
other you're gonna watch me
and that's and that's something that i
brought to the table when i bring that
same kind of mindset to um to writing
into directing and that's something that
i
i also heard this from from will will
smith
where he talks about there's other
actors that are more talented than him
better looking than him he says but you
will not outwork me
and that's the mindset that i have now
uh which kind of comes from it's like
the cousin to what i just mentioned
earlier is the same thing i would not be
outworked so when i write i i i write
15 pages a day
when i'm when i'm working on a script
after i've outlined it i do 15 pages no
matter how long it takes if it takes me
12 hours 15 hours eight hours i will not
be outworked i get my 15 pages in that
means that in a week i can finish a full
script for one hour
tv show in two weeks i can finish my
first draft of my feature film so once
it's outlined
two weeks my feature film is done my
first draft is done
has anyone said courtney just wanted to
take a break for a week
slow down a little
yeah have they asked me to slow down
from
from what in any respect like i see you
working so hard why not just take a
break oh
well just because i work hard doesn't
mean that i don't take breaks i do take
breaks i believe in taking breaks but
when i'm working i'm working so
um
one thing i don't do is i don't
i don't constantly work i believe you
have to buy out the time
to take care of yourself take care of
your body take care of your sanity so
i'm not working all the way through at
all i don't believe in that at all but
okay so let me give an example
so
um
if if you're the network and you hire me
to to write a script and we have a
deadline
i'm gonna get that script done earlier
than that deadline because i want to get
it done i'm going to put it away like
for a day or two come back to it take a
look at it then begin my rewrites on it
and then send it in for my notes and the
whole shebang um
but once i'm done with that project i'm
done like i don't i don't keep playing
with it i don't mess with it um i may
have other ideas that i want to do for
other projects that i want to write but
it doesn't it doesn't um
dominate my life like i believe
in
working hard and putting that timing for
that but i believe in
putting it away and then going to spend
time with family or friends or doing
other things
if that first job had never happened
with michael jackson
do you think you'd still have been a
professional dancer and
be where you are now
yeah that's a very good question if the
first job for michael had never happened
the answer to whether or not i would
still be a professional dancer is yes
because at that point i was still a very
good dancer it just means that i would
not have gotten that job now even if i
didn't get remember the time i would
still be working with michael at some
point because
and i really believe in this talent can
be denied like you can't not deny talent
you may not always get the job you may
be the most talented actor actress
you may not get that particular job but
you're good there'll be another job that
will come around that will allow you to
showcase your skill set so yeah i still
would have been a dancer i should have
been successful as a dancer i would have
still become a choreographer i just
would not have done remember the time i
wouldn't have that story to share but i
would have done something else
was there something that a mentor told
you early on that you that you really
just that was your mantra you never
forgot it and it drove you
in everything you did good question did
i have a mentor that told me something
that drove me i know you said you had a
dance t-shirt that was similar to the
devi allen character
who really kind of like expected the
best from you and then they helped you
yeah i did have a mentor that was a
dance teacher she never told me anything
that necessarily was like profound that
allowed me to like
just hone in on that and and live my
life according to that i think a lot of
a lot of what i did was
self
um i pushed myself
and then she helped to validate what i
was doing so it wasn't that she said one
particular thing she taught me just a
way to live and a way to think in
regards to my dancing uh
just again pushing myself
beyond my boundaries like i i came in
with this mindset of like i was only a
hip-hop dancer and i could only do maybe
a little bit of jazz but she pushed me
to believe that no you can do more than
that you can do ballet you can do modern
you can do other things so if anything
she's the one who kind of opened my head
to the fact that
there are other styles of dance that i
can learn then i can apply and i can use
this as a skill set when i do go out to
audition i can be a lot more
well-rounded
so she was she helped to change that
mindset but it wasn't one thing that she
said it was just how she
how she really pushed me to
go after my greatest potential in
regards to what i could bring to the
dance world